The Joe Rogan experience. You know, Einstein made three,
three big mistakes at the end of his career. In the 1930s,
he argued that black holes don't exist. Gravitational waves don't exist.
And quantum mechanics doesn't have spooky action at a distance. You know,
he argued all these three things at the end of his career when he was the most
experienced, you know, and he was wrong.
We have experimental data that shows that he was wrong on all three.
And what is the lesson from that? Even the smartest person, you know,
that was last century in physics can be wrong if he works
on the frontier, because you never know exactly where the truth lies. Okay,
you have to take risks.
And if people want to just demonstrate that they're smart,
it's better not to take risks. And how do you not take risks?
If you work on ideas that will never be tested against data against the
evidence.
So if you work on superstring theory or on extra dimensions or on the
multiverse,
you can do intellectual gymnastics and impress your colleagues that you're smart
and you will get jobs. You will get recognition, you will get awards.
If that's your goal, that's a completely legitimate framework.
But I see it as a violation of our commitment as physicist
to understand nature. You know, it's not really about us.
Physics is a dialogue with nature. You listen to nature,
you see what the experiments are telling you and you learn,
and perhaps you are wrong. You take risks. It's not about your image.
It's not getting more likes on Twitter.
So that's why I don't really care what my colleagues say.
If this object looked unusual,
I just talk about it the way I would talk about any other normally,
and people were asking, you know, why isn't he backing down? Well,
I will back down as soon as there is evidence. Generally,
if I saw a photograph showing that it's a rock,
or if I saw some other objects like it,
that we definitely have clear evidence that they are naturally produced,
then I will give up on it. Like, and I'm not afraid of being wrong. You know,
that's, that's part of any work on the frontiers.
This is my thoughts on the quantum physics aspect of this.
I think there's not enough people that understand what they're doing to
criticize them. So there's no social pressure.
The difference between that and the concept of exploring extraterrestrial life
is extraterrestrial. Life is inexorably connected to nonsense.
It's an actually collected, it's connected to crazy.
People think that they're talking to aliens, they're channeling people.
I have to answer. I have an answer to that suppose.
There was a whole literature on COVID-19 that is completely fictitious.
You know, like people were saying crazy things about COVID-19 that make no sense
whatsoever. And there was a, oh, you can find them. Yeah, there were,
there were books about it. There were films about it. Now,
would that mean that scientists,
reputable scientists should not work on a vaccine for
People that say nonsense don't care.
Um, COVID 19 is a real thing and you could prove it in a lab quickly instantly.
I mean, it's, it's universally acknowledged as being a real thing, right?
The problem with extra terrestrial life is there's no evidence that it's true.
Well, but if you step on the grass and you say, look,
it doesn't grow then obviously, because you're stepping on it.
So if you bully anyone that works on the subject,
then young people don't enter into this research field.
If you don't fund it at all, you dry it up. Then there will not be discoveries.
Now you say, look,
they're not discovered I step on the grass and it doesn't grow.
Therefore there is no point in continuing to wait for it to grow. I agree with.
No, I, I think it's, uh,
I think it's a side effect of our social interactions.
And I think a lot of professors, a lot of people in academia, they come from,
you know, maybe a more socially awkward environment. They come from,
uh, a lot of people that get into teaching.
A lot of people that get into being professors,
they weren't like the class king.
They weren't like the most popular person and social interactions with them. Uh,
you know, maybe they were bullied. Maybe they're like Dr. Carl Hart. Who's uh,
an academic was on a couple of days ago was actually talking about this very
subject and that a lot of academics, they, uh, they see,
they try to undermine other people's work and they do so in kind of a bullying
fashion. Yeah.
Because it's all about the ego. You see, I was asked by the Harvard Gazette,
the Harvard university Gazette, which is the prov of Harvard, you know,
this official, uh, newspaper. They asked me,
uh, what is the one thing you would like to change about the world? You know,
a very big question. Yeah. So I wrote an essay. I said,
I want my colleagues to behave more like kids because as a
kid, I remember that, you know, I was mostly curious about the world.
I would not be afraid of making mistakes.
I wasn't worried about my ego or my something really strange,
uh,
happens to those kids that take risks and are not worried about themselves so
much. Uh, something bad happens to them when they become tenured.
Professors in academia,
tenure is supposed to give you the freedom to explore, you know,
directions that might, may turn out to be wrong. You know,
that's what Einstein demonstrated at the end of his career.
So you would expect people to take advantage of that. But instead,
once professors become tenured for life,
meaning that there is no risk to their job,
they are starting to pursue Horners and
towards tattoos recognition, they are afraid of making mistakes.
They build these echo chambers,
where they have students and postdocs repeating their mantras so that
their voice will sound louder so that they will get even more recognition.
Now I say this, you know,
the scientific inquiry is not about us.
It's about the dialogue with nature, trying to figure out what nature is.
It's not about elevating our status, our image, you know,
we will all die in several decades. So, you know, it's really not that now,
you know, actually Lex Friedman was asking me, Avi, you know,
so much, uh, what do you think is the meaning of life? Uh,
and I told him, look, um, I don't, I think we just exist. You know,
any meaning that we assign now, uh,
will go away in a billion years,
cause the sun will boil off the ocean on earth. There will be no life on earth.
You know,
one of these things that we call meaning they are really temporary in the big,
big sky. We should just enjoy the process, just like eating good food. You know,
I will not mention another example, uh, you know, doing these,
like eating good food, you enjoy the process. So learning about the world,
figuring out what the world is, is very enjoyable. You know,
I, I,
if I realize something nobody else did and understand
something that nobody else did, it gives me pleasure.
So just the process of doing that, that gives me meaning,
because I enjoy it, you know?
So you should live your life in a way that you enjoy it. If you like good food,
that's good enough, you know, you can live your life, just eating, you know,
that's what animals do. Yeah, yeah. Right. Uh, can have sex.
You can do all kinds,
but if you want a deeper sort of satisfaction,
I think understanding the world is what humans are capable of doing.
And that's really a deeper level of, of enjoying life. So to speak.
There's a lot of examples of professors going out on a limb,
being incorrect and then being punished, being ridiculed,
losing their status in the community or even being correct,
but not having the support of your peers who turn on you and turn against
you. And then it turns out ultimately they were correct,
but there's very little, very little repercussions for that.
And there's this thing that happens with people and ideas,
where they get scared to take on something that could easily make them
look ridiculous. And the best example of that is extra terrestrial life.
That is, it's so easy to get ridiculed for believing in it.
It's like big foot. And then extraterrestrial life.
To change that. I say, this is a subject.
The scientific community can address with scientific tools, okay.
With telescopes, let's discuss it. The public is interested. You know,
let's forget about the past, then look for a better future. Right?
And then my point is, uh,
there are many examples for unborn babies, you know,
in science where people were ridiculed and ideas were never pursued
or delayed, you know, for example, looking for planets around other stars,
you know, that was something,
something that was suggested in 1952 by an astronomer called auto Strava,
who said, if you take Jupiter, the planet, Jupiter, put it close to the sun,
then it will move the sun back and forth a lot.
And you could tell if there is a closing Jupiter near other stars,
by looking at their motion or looking [inaudible], the star comes in front of it
, transiting from, he suggested that 1952 for four decades, astronomers ignored that.
Why? Because they said,
we know that Jupiter in our solar system is far away and we
understand why it's far away.
And therefore we shouldn't waste our time even looking for something like that.
Then in 1995,
a couple of astronomers found a hot Jupiter, Jupiter close to a star,
and they got the Nobel prize a couple of years ago for that. So my point is,
this is an example for baby that was eventually born. So people would say,
oh yeah, science works. You see, eventually it was found.
My point is it took four decades in those four decades. You know,
we could have done a lot to advance science.
And the other thing is, I say, okay, this baby was born,
but there might have been other babies that were not born, you know,
ideas that were put forward and were scrutinized for no good reason just because
people are close-minded. And you know,
the strange thing for me is they see a lot of innovation in the commercial
sector. You see, uh, you know, Jeff Bezos, Elon Musk, you know, apple,
uh, Google, uh,
they have parts of their companies that are doing
blue sky research, you know, things that are not applied.
It all started with IBM. And before that,
and then in academia, I see a lot of conservatives and much,
much less, um, innovation as in the commercials.
Now the commercial sector is after making a profit,
you would expect academia to be even more open-minded, but it's not.
And to me that has, that must change.
Is this something that you had as an idea before publishing this, this,
all these thoughts about extraterrestrial life and did that accentuate it for
you? Yeah.
Yeah. I didn't expect the response that I received. It doesn't bother me. Um,
you know, in my, uh, I have, uh,
800 more than 800 papers that I published and eight books in,
in, in all of these, I talk about anomalies, you know,
over the years I talked about anomalies in other contexts, you know,
like in the early universe. And,
and then when I mentioned speculative ideas in other
contexts, there was no pushback. You know, it, it,
it wasn't threatening to anyone. It wasn't,
but something about the subject of extraterrestrial life bothers.
And frankly, you know, I'm just like a kid.
I try to be as close as possible to the way I was at a young age.
I'm just doing it innocently,
working on the subject the same way I work on other subjects.
And I get this response that now the only reason the two of us are speaking,
you know,
and I get a lot of media attention is because my colleagues are not behaving the
same way. If everyone would accept, you know, I think it's common sense.
What is common sense to me? If everyone would accept it,
I would be no different than the person next to me. You wouldn't speak,
you wouldn't be speaking to me.
No, I still would catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free.
Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the Gerry on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan.